ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEANTIME NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. HURRY ARAMBULA.
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN CALDERON LEO
CERVANTES GEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY BLACKY LEE
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN.
O'DONNELL GIPSON PETRIE-NORRIS
CORP QUICK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE TEAM
CALAVERAS BE APPROVED VIA VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. GUIDE US
ALL I'M BLESSED TO MEMBERS OF
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. YOU ORDER
COUNSELOR AND GUIDE. GIVE THEM
SATISFACTION IN THEIR WORK FOR
YOU OR THE JOY OF THOSE WHO ARE
. FAITH FILLED AND THE GLORY OF
THE HUMBLE. MAY ALL THE
DELIBERATIONS GIVE RISE TO
UNDERSTANDING. AND FURTHER THE
CAUSE OF EQUAL JUSTICE. MAY
THEIR DETERMINATION TO BE
HONORED AND RESPECTED. IN YOU WE
PLACE OUR TRUST. FOR WE BELIEVE
YOU HAVE CALLED US TO SERVE THE
STATE. BY YOUR DIVINE
INSPIRATION. WE WILL REACH THE
DESTINY. YOU HAVE IN MIND FOR US
I MEAN. WE OFFER OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
THIS BALLARD CANYON. WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO AS A MEMBER DAVIS AT OF
PLEASE LEAVE US IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. THANK YOU READY
BEGIN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THERE ARE. PUBLIC. YEAH ALL. YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SACRAMENTO TUESDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY BED AT
SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE JACKIE-
WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORTY
FOURTH DISTRICT RESIDING SHE
FOCUS REPORT OF A DEATH RECORDS
REYES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
OF THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS.
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATION SUBMISSIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION TO
REFERENCE THE BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY RETURNING
THE LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
AND FOR FUNERAL DEATH IN THE
FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM. ON
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THAT'S
RIGHT YES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FOR FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
COOPER NAZARIAN TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY EIGHT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO STRIKE THE
FOLLOWING VETOED ITEMS FROM THE
FILE AND I WOULD ASK THAT THE
CLERK READ THE ITEMS. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE VETOES TO BE
STRICKEN. I AM TO SYMBOL SIX
SIXTEEN STONE ITEM THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY THREE
FORMER MEMBER GONZALEZ ITEM FOR
SOME LEGAL TEN SEVENTY FOUR
FORMER MEMBER GONZALEZ ITEM
EIGHT IS A LEGAL TROUBLE SEVEN
FOREVER I AM TENNYSON LEGAL
SEVENTY SALAS ITEM ELEVEN
ASSEMBLY BEFORE SIXTEEN KALRA
ITEM TWELVE SOME LEGAL TEN
TWENTY ONE MAYES. ITEM FOURTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO THREE
LEVINE ITEM FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
BEFORE I'M FORTY FOUR LEAD I'M
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY SET FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE RADIUS ITEM TWENTY
ASSEMBLY WILL TO SEVENTY NINE
MURATSUCHI I'M TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY BILLTHREE THIRTY NINE
LEE ITEM TWENTY TWO WAS A MIDDLE
FOR FORTY SIX MAYES I DON'T
TWENTY FOUR SO PEOPLE TEND
SEVENTY COOPER. I'M TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH FIVE HOLDEN
I'M TWENTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE TWENTY TWO BOERNER HORVATH
I'M TWENTY EIGHT IS A MIDDLE TO
TWENTY SIX RAMEAU'S I'M TWENTY
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
NINE FORMER MEMBER KAMLAGER ITEM
THIRTY ONE ASSEMBLY BEFORE
TWELVE REYES I'M THIRTY TWO
ASSEMBLY WILL SIX OH THREE
MCCARTY I AM VERY REASONABLE
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE GREAT. ITEM
THIRTY FIVE A SYMBOL TEN THIRTY
FIVE SALAS ITEM THIRTY SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN FORTY SEVEN
FRIEDMAN ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
CYNICAL TWELVE FIFTEEN
BOERNER HORVATH I'M THIRTY EIGHT
A SYMBOL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHTEEN
I'M THIRTY NINE A SYMBOL
THIRTEEN OH TWO COURT ITEM FORTY
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN GABRIEL AND ITEM
FORTY TWO SYMBOL. FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO. ACTION TO BE ARE STRUCK. I
REQUEST YOU GOT CONSENT TO THE
RULE TO WITHDRAW THE FOLLOW
BILLS BY THE SO BUDGET AND
FISCAL COMMITTEE FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND PLAY THEM ON THIRD
READING SB ONE THIRTEEN SB ONE
FOURTEEN SB ONE FIFTEEN SB ONE
SIXTEEN SB ONE SEVENTEEN. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO GRANTING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. MISTER FLOOR
WE WITHHOLD NOW SINCE IT HAS A
ROLL CALL VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
FLORA MEMBERS THERE'S INJECTION
TO GRANTING CONSENT ON THIS
ITEM. MISS RAMOS MOVES AND MISS
BONTA SECONDS THAT. THE RULES BE
SUSPENDED. IT TAKES THIRTY EIGHT
VOTES TO SUSPEND THE RULES WORK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO THOSE NUMBERS IS TAKES THIRTY
EIGHT VOTES. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES AYE AYES ARE FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS ARE EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS I'M ORDERING
THE DESK TO REMAIN OPEN TO
RECEIVE POSSIBLE BUDGET RELATED
AMENDMENTS. WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
PROFILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FORTY
THREE THE ITEMS NOT STRICKEN
SHALL BE CONTINUED. I AM SOME
RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING ITEMS SHALL BE PASSED
AND RETAIN AND SENATE THIRD
AND RETAINS. MEMBERS WILL BE
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR THIS IS FILE
ITEMS FIFTY ONE THROUGH FIFTY
THREE THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR. BEFORE
WE WILL VOTE WE WILL TAKE UP
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE TO FIFTY
THREE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE PURPOSES OF ALLEN CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL PASSENGER SAFETY WEEK
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO LUNAR NEW YEAR AND
HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY BOTH OF
THE SCHOOL CHOICE WEEK. THE
CLERK WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE.
OUT ON THE WATER TO THE
RESOLUTION. MEMBERS THIS VOTE IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE IF YOU
WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTIONS ON
CONSENT PLEASE VOTE NOW. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS. WILL
MOVE TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL PASSENGER
SAFETY WEEK. OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES EITHER
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS OR ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
BURKE WILL READ REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO IN HOUSE RESOLUTION
EIGHTY TWO I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. WE HAVE SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR DESK FOR YOUR ANNOUNCEMENT
REGARDING THE ASSEMBLY
OBSERVANCE OF LUNAR NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
OF ON BEHALF ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IS MY HONOR. TO RISE AND
WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY LUNAR NEW
YEAR. THIS YEAR THE NEW YEAR
BEGAN ON FEBRUARY FIRST
WELCOMING IN THE YEAR OF THE
TIGER. THE TIGER IS THE THIRD
ANIMAL OF THE ZODIAC AND AS SOON
AS A SYMBOL OF STRENGTH AND
COURAGE. THAT WARDS OFF EVIL.
FOR MANY ASIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA LUNAR NEW YEAR IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT HOLIDAYS
OF THE YEAR. THE REPRESENTS A
LONG STANDING CULTURAL
TRADITIONS. ALTHOUGH MANY
FAMILIES ARE ONCE AGAIN
CELEBRATE FROM THEIR HOUSEHOLDS.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO SHARE
SOME OF THE TRADITIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEW YEAR. ON
EACH OF YOUR DESK YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED A RED ENVELOPE AND A
LUNAR NEW YEAR CALENDAR. EACH
RED ENVELOPE CONTAINS A GOLD
CHOCOLATE COINS IS A TIME
HONORED TRADITION. THAT WHICH IS
GOOD FORTUNE A LOT. FOR THOSE
WHO RECEIVE THE ENVELOPE. YOU'LL
SEE THE CHINESE CHARACTER FU
PRINT ON THE ENVELOPE. WHICH
MEANS GOOD FORTUNE. BLESSINGS
ARE A LOT. THIS CHARACTERS ALSO
COMMONLY SEEN ON DOORS WINDOWS
AND OTHER NEW YEAR DECORATIONS
TO BRING PEACE AND FORTUNE INTO
THE HOUSEHOLD. WE HOPE YOU ENJOY
FINDING YEARS OR THE ACT ON THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR CALENDAR AND
CELEBRATED FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME. AS YOU RING IN THE YEAR OF
THE TIGER INVITE YOU TO WEAR
SOME RED WHICH MANY OF YOU ON
THE FLOOR ARE DOING AT THIS
MOMENT. FOR GOOD LUCK AND ORDER
SOME DUMPLINGS AND NOODLES YOUR
LOCAL ASIAN RESTAURANTS THE
CELEBRATE THE NEW YEAR. HAPPY
NEW YEAR. ALONG WITH THE
PRESIDING LUNAR NEW YEAR THERE'S
ANOTHER GOOD REASON TO WEAR THE
COLOR RED TODAY. TODAY IS OUR
ANNUAL CAPITAL GOES RED DAY. THE
MEMBERS OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND SEVERAL COLLEAGUES ARE
WEARING RED TODAY TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE- ALARMING
RISE OF CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
IT AFFECTS PEOPLE OF EVERY AGE
AND RACE. IT IS THE NUMBER ONE
KILLER OF WOMEN. BY INCREASING
THE AWARENESS OF THIS RISK WE
CAN SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIVES. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED RETURNS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. QUORUM IS NOT YET
LIFTED MEMBERS. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THIS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS EVERY DAY
THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT RISSER LIES FOR
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITY THEY DO THIS WITH
PRIDE AND SELFISHNESS AUTHOR
TYLER TO HAN MAYBE ALTERNATE
SACRIFICE A FORTY FOUR YEARS OF
AGE ALSO GONNA HAND BEGINS
CAREER AS A POLICE OFFICER THE
CITY CITRUS HEIGHTS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE JOINED THE CALL
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND LATER THE
ELK GROVE POLICE DEPARTMENT
TWENTY SIXTEEN. I HAD THE HONOR
OF BEING TIED THAT YEAR THE
NATIONAL NIGHT OUT OF IT IN MY
DISTRICT. HE CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING A
DIFFERENCE I THINK COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE ALSO WHEN A HAND.
REACHES LACK TO PROTECT AND
SERVE THE CITY OF OAK GROVE. WAS
A PROUD OF DEDICATED RESIDENT.
THE TOWN OF RESCUE ALSO WITH A
HAND A US AIR FORCE VETERAN.
SERVICE COUNTRY STATE AND
COMMUNITY WITHOUT ANY
DISTINCTION. OFF TO HIM IT'S A-
BY HIS WIFE JESSICA. TWO
CHILDREN AUSTIN CITY. AND I
SHOULD ALSO NOTE HIS WIFE THE
POLICE OFFICER IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT HIS PARENTS AND THREE
SIBLINGS MY HEARTFELT
CONDOLENCES AND PRAYERS GO OUT
TO HIS FAMILY HIS FRIENDS THE
CONGREGATION AND HIS FELLOW
OFFICERS THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF OFFICER TIE. WITH HIM
. THANK YOU MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
WITH THE QUORUM CALL. MISTER IS
THERE ANY ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TODAY S. THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF A TITAN
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
RICHARD CLOSE. WHO PASSED AWAY
MONDAY UNEXPECTEDLY. HE WAS A
MONUMENTAL ADVOCATE IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS
FROM THE HALLS OF CONGRESS TO
THE STATE CAPITOL TO CITY HALL.
HE WAS RELENTLESS IN THIS FIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY GOT ITS FAIR SHARE AND
WAS WELL REPRESENTED. BORN AND
RAISED IN ANDOVER MASSACHUSETTS
RICHARD ATTENDED THE WHARTON
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA AND
BOSTON UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
BEFORE MOVING TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WITH HIS WIFE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. PURSUING A
LEGAL CAREER AND BECOMING
INVOLVED IN THE SHERMAN OAKS
COMMUNITY WHERE HE LIVED. IN THE
SEVENTIES AFTER JOINING THE
SHERMAN OAKS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION- RICHARD BEGAN
WORKING FOR PROP THIRTEEN.
BECAUSE HOWARD JARVIS CAME TEN
MEETING. WHO ALSO HAPPENED TO BE
A RESIDENT IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND- COMMUNICATED ABOUT
WHAT HE WANTED TO DO AND HE WON
RICHARD OVER. AND SO RICHARD
STARTED TO WORK ON IT HIS ROLE
AS A COMMUNITY LEADER. AT SILVA
AS PRESIDENT AS PRESIDENT
RICHARD WORKED ON ON ON THE
PASSAGE OF PROP THIRTEEN.
PROPOSITION YOU WHICH IMPACTED
DEVELOPMENT CITY WIDE AND THE
CARPOOL LANE ON THE FOUR OH FIVE
FREEWAY THROUGH THE SUPPORT BUT
A PASS. RICHARDS LAW PRACTICE
FOCUSED ON LAND USE ENTITLEMENTS
ADMINISTRATIVE AND REGULATORY
LAW. PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND
FINANCING MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES. GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS AND ADVOCACY RICHARD
WAS NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR
HIS EXPERTISE ON LEGAL ISSUES
RELATED TO HIS HOUSING AND REAL
ESTATE SPECIALTIES THE LEGAL
POLITICAL AND BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES EACH RECOGNIZE
RICHARD SKILLS AND CREATING
COMMUNITY OPPORTUNITY AND VALUED
HIS EVER ASTUTE JUDGMENT. IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS RICHARD WAS
FRUSTRATED AND FED UP AT THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WAS CONTINUING
TO PAY MORE IN TAXES AND RECEIVE
LESSONS SERVICES THAN THE REST
OF LOS ANGELES. SO HE
SPEARHEADED VALUE VOTE A GROUP
THAT SECURED A BALLOT MEASURE
THAT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY TO BECOME ITS
OWN CITY. ALTHOUGH THE BALLOT
MEASURE FAILED LOS ANGELES
UNDERSTOOD THAT IN ORDER TO
SUCCEED YOU COULD NOT IGNORE NOR
TAKE FOR GRANTED THE SUPPORT OF
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. WHO DID
NOT AGREE WITH RICHARDS
POLITICS. ME INCLUDED. COULD
RESPECT HIS APPROACH
RELENTLESSLY ADVOCATING FOR HIS
COMMUNITY FOR BETTER
REPRESENTATION AND BETTER
SERVICES FOR THE VALLEY HIS
LEADERSHIP AND GUIDANCE STEERED
SILVA TO BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
FORTY YEARS THE NEW YORK TIMES
REFER TO RICHARD AS THE KING OF
THE VALLEY- COLLEAGUES. RICHARD
AND I DISAGREED SO MUCH ON SO
MANY THINGS THAT IT WASN'T EVEN
FUNNY AT TIMES I EVEN QUESTIONED
WHY HE WOULD WANT TO SOMETIMES
GRAB COFFEE WITH ME OR MEET FOR
BREAKFAST WITH ME. AT OUR
FAVORITE PLACE ALI'S WHICH
CLOSED DOWN UNFORTUNATELY A FEW
YEARS AGO. I IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WHEN I FIRST RAN
FOR OFFICE- I ASKED TO MEET WITH
HIM WHEN I MET WITH THEM HE SAID
YOU GOT MY ENDORSEMENT. WITH HIS
NEW YORK ACCENT THAT HE COULDN'T
REALLY HIDE EVEN AFTER FORTY
YEARS OF LIVING IN THE VALLEY. I
SAID GEE THANKS I REALLY DIDN'T
EXPECT YOUR ENDORSEMENT I JUST
DIDN'T WANT YOU TO REALLY GO OUT
AGAINST ME MUCH. AND HE HE SAID
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DISAGREE BUT I
LIKE YOU. AND YOUR CHARACTER
COUNTS AND SO- YOU KNOW I'M
GONNA YELL AT YOU FROM TIME TO
TIME BUT WE'RE GOING TO WORK
WELL TOGETHER- AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT WAS. WE WOULD HAVE VERY
ASTUTE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
DYNAMICS OF POLITICS WE
SOMETIMES DIDN'T AGREE ON THE
FINAL OUTCOME. BUT THE- WE WERE
IN SYNC ON THE TENANTS AND THE
CHRONOLOGY OF EVENTS THAT WE
WERE EXPECTING TO HAPPEN. AND
SO- I WILL SORELY MISS HIS-
GUIDANCE AND HIS. OF THE
DISCOURSE THAT WE HAD- SO MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES GO OUT TO
RICHARD'S WIFE SALLY HIS SON
MATTHEW. OF HIS WIFE- TRISTEN A
DAUGHTER DR ABBY- AMADOR AND HER
HUSBAND JOSH AND FOUR GRANDSONS
RICHARD WILL BE VERY MISSED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUESTED TURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ. AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. LIVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS. JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT WILL MEET
AT ONE O'CLOCK TODAY. IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF UPCOMING BIRTHDAYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
ON FEBRUARY FOURTH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US ON FEBRUARY
SIXTH. HAPPY BIRTHDAY MEMBERS.
RECENSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY FEBRUARY FOURTH NO
SESSION NO CHECK IN MONDAY
FEBRUARY SEVENTH FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED AND
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTRANSLATIONS AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THAT AT THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH AT ONE
PM.